[Music]
Hello, not a single news broadcast for
several weeks has
mentioned the Clear Stream affair.  But
what exactly is Clearstream?  A
mysterious money laundering operation, the key to
many cases of drug trafficking,
arms trafficking and/or globalization and
layoffs.  Our guest today
is Denis Robert, journalist, writer,
artist, author 10 years ago of an
investigation into Clearstream.  Clearstream
is a financial clearing house
based in Luxembourg which was
then unknown to the general public and whose
shady dealings he denounced.
Today, everyone in France
knows Clearstream.  This has
obviously become synonymous with a state scandal.
10 years of legal battles, 60
trials, hundreds of bailiffs at your
door, and some serious enmities in the
political world nonetheless.  There are
also some among your colleagues, the
press community, and then a flash of lightning and
then night after 10 years.  So, on
February 3, 2011, it's still very fresh,
very recent, the Court of Cassation
definitively ruled on your case and recognized
your work as a
journalist and investigator.
The finances of the press, well, from an
economic point of view, it's a
catastrophe for the
print media, that's obvious.  I had lunch
with a friend earlier.
Sales of Nouvel, for example, have
fallen by 16%; sales of the weight have
fallen by 16%.  In the last quarter,
OPS's sales fell by 14 and
L'Express, which did well, fell
by 10. Libération is in a
catastrophic situation.  It's even more than that, it's
artificial respiration at their level.
Where does this come from?  What does this come from?
Well, it comes from, well, the internet
came and ate everything up, you know.  And then that
also comes from the content that is
for sale which corresponds more, let's
say naively, to the desires of the
readers or the people who pay
people.  Do you think this represents a
loss of trust among readers and
listeners in the press in general?   When it comes to the
profession of journalism, I believe that
firstly there is a
considerable supply of information, which is
drowned in this supply, so it is very
complicated.  News is easy,
information is much more
complicated, so it needs to be cross-checked.
Finally, all of this requires work,
time and then uh uh how to say
the offer which is proposed no
longer visibly corresponds in
very broad terms to the desires of the
readers or buyers of newspapers or
subscribers.  Finally, so we can see that there is a
kind of subsidence like this.
That said, it's not a tragedy,
it's a minor tragedy.  It's a
trend, it's heavy, it's complicated,
but at the same time, uh, how to
say it, there is a responsibility on the part of
publishers, press owners, and
journalists.  So I'm not going to cry
with everyone else.  That's how it is.   So.
In terms of trust, yes or
no, do you think that the population, the
press customer, has
lost trust in their press?
It's difficult to answer this type
of question because it's a
generalization.  I think that,
generally speaking, yes, I think there is a
lack of trust.  That said, uh,
the Causac affair, to talk about it,
showed that when
you have a strong journalistic will,
you can overthrow
powers, and at the same time, it's also
a constraint because it's the
media, they had it against the press
.  And I understand them.
You were questioned today at the
Senate and the National Assembly, and what did
you
tell them?   It's
really a
parliamentary mission on journalism
and the protection of sources, that's the
starting point but it's a bit
broader than the protection of sources.
So it was a conversation
that lasted 1 hour where I was
questioned a lot about Clearstream and about
the difficulties I had
personally experienced.  And if you want, well, if
you want one of my
ideas that I have developed, in fact,
we cannot isolate the problem
of protecting sources from all the
problems of
protecting the journalist.  Because
talking about sources means talking about
defamation issues,
image rights, the Gesso law,
freedom of expression, all of that
.  So it's all part of a whole
.  The profession is losing its
bearings, losing its identity.  At the
same time, the world is moving faster than
she is, you know.  So, there are
adjustments, there are rules, uh,
there are lots of questions that
arise.  There are people who want to
create an order of journalists, there are
people who want to create a kind of
high authority of the digital press
with the one that would be similar to
the high authority of the audiovisual.  There are
bills
that can be hyper-protective for
journalism that are made at the expense of
other things. There is
also the fact that people who feel
insulted or humiliated by
articles have the right to defend themselves.
So it's a question of
considerable complexity, and so
these MPs are trying to
find a way through all of this.  Their
approach seems to me to be consistent
and honest.  And in France, we are
lagging behind countries like
Belgium, for example, which have
chosen different paths.  I know because I was
heard by commissions
in Belgium.  They want to create a
specific press offense, they
want there are lots of things
circulating at the moment and there are
and I think that François Hollande,
regardless of everything else, is
someone who is much less
freedom-suppressing than he was, in this
matter.  So the will is of
these MPs, I think they are
aware that at the moment there are
upheavals, there are
things happening and that
we cannot simply say
let things take their course.  But at the
same time, as soon as you touch on one
aspect of it, it's something that
is very fragile because it
very quickly becomes a threat to freedom or it
becomes an open door to
all the nonsense we see on the
internet.  So, uh, so they
questioned you a lot about ClearSAM
because there was a lack of understanding
of the case, there was a lack of
understanding of
investigative journalism techniques.
No, but what's happening is that, uh,
I am the perfect example.  I
think there are
very few other
examples of what
Canadians call
bayonets procedures.  That is to say, you have
bombarded yourself with lawsuits and in the end even if you
win you lose because
the time you spend
defending yourself,
time the world moves on and then there is
a kind of steamroller
like that.  So how can we prevent these
complaints?  I never said that
even Clairstream, even the most rotten of the
rotten, have the right to sue for
defamation.  It's a normal game, there is
justice, judges judge,
journalists do their job,
writers finally do theirs because afterwards there are
problems of difference in status
between journalists and writers.  All of this is
a bit complicated too.  And on the other side, well, simply put,
we can clearly see that when we
are facing oligopolies or
multinationals or guys
loaded with money who are being
attacked in the press, whether on the
internet or in papers, the guys
file complaints, file
complaints and then you are like in
a game of ping-pong, you only have
one paddle, you are facing
players in all countries, that's what happened to me
.  So how can we prevent this
when they legally have the right to
do it?  So I think we need to
consider changing the
law on defamation, meaning that we can no
longer demand money from
journalists; there are things that need to be done.
But what I advocate is something a little complicated
, it's what
I tried to defend in
the assembly, which is that when I
often found myself in this situation where they hit you with
lawsuits demanding
a maximum amount of money, basically,
I make it short, but then you have to
find the legal terms.  When
history proves you right because
it always takes time, the truth is,
the guys who ask you for money, well,
you have to multiply by 10, by 20, by 100
what they asked you for, to the benefit of the
journalist.  That way, they will hesitate
before filing complaints, and because there is
a risk for them too if they
lose, because the problem with
defamation is that the guys who
file complaints when they lose,
or when they talk nonsense
, when they make
accusations that are false, well, they don't care,
or even the day before a
trial, they can withdraw their
complaints.  That said, the damage is already done
, you know.  So I believe that we need to
be inventive on these
issues because one of the,
I'll give you an example, in
Paris at the court, in the, how should I
say, the court that deals with
defamation trials, 3 years ago,
not 3 years ago, there was in 2000, at the beginning of the
2000s, uh, when I released my
books.  It took roughly 2
to 3 years between the time someone
filed a defamation complaint and the
time the complaint was either investigated
or judged.  Between two and three
years passed.  They are very, very long.
Today, between 2 and 3
months have passed.  So one might think that
justice is getting better, that it's working well,
but not at all.  This is because there are
fewer and fewer
defamation cases.  And there are fewer and fewer of them
.  This is not good news.   This is
very bad news.  This
means that press publishers or
journalists are so
afraid now of not even losing
lawsuits, but they are afraid of lawsuits
because the procedures are expensive, which
obviously leads to self-censorship and
censorship, and that is dramatic.
That is to say, freedom
of expression and democracy
suffer from this.  So, and so I am a
kind of vigilante who says
damn, we have to be careful because, well,
even though the
legal battles I fought,
which lasted 10 years for me and which
I finally won, are
emblematic battles,
but I fought them for a
group of other journalists,
people who are concerned about this
freedom, and it was more important at a certain point
because I was often
criticized, I don't even really
want to talk about it anymore, but the
reason I fought
legally was to create this
jurisprudence that exists today and
that offers more freedom to everyone
.  Simply put, this needs to move
forward, that's all.  So does
the fact that journalists do not
present figures correctly
or in an exaggerated or
exaggerated way imply
journalistic misconduct or a lack of information?
But of course, your question
contains the answer itself.  Obviously, obviously
.  The press, you speak
of the economic press, let's say the
financial press is undoubtedly the
most
subservient press to the banks
and to the financial groups.  I have, there is, there is,
I think that the
financial press, or rather
financial journalism, I may be,
how should I say, succinct in my
statement, but does not exist.  That is to say, there are only
newspapers, in fact, well, let's take Les Echos,
they try to do their job but it's still
not great.
It's better than a number
of other titles, but it's not
terrible.  And the financial pages of Le
Figaro, like those of Le Monde,
clearly show that behind them there are
pressure groups, press groups and
so on, and that we are generally
bombarded with indices,
figures, stock markets and everything that are
completely falsified.  That is to say, there is a
kind of big
lie around all this and I do
n't believe in the conspiracy, I don't believe in all that,
but I know very well that these
newspapers are paid for by Arnaud, by Pino, by
the banks
and that there are advertisers and that there is all that
and that we can't displease them
.  And I saw it with
Cirstream, it was the pinnacle because, well, at the time when
I was, well, I don't want to talk about
that again, I'm
interested, so legislators
also get their information through the press,
so in terms of being
poisoned by a lack of
information, there are very few
ways to get
informed outside of the press,
apart from blogs.  So now I'm taking you
to the blogs.  By law,
bloggers are forced to perform the same duties as
journalists.  We will be
condemned the same, we will be judged the same,
except that we don't have a press card.
How do you explain that?  What is
your point of view?  That's one of the
questions I was
asked today.  It takes a lot of
time, a lot of... Me, I'm not...
I think that any answer to that
will be imperfect because at the same time,
we can't consider that just any random person
who goes on the internet
starts uttering insults or
saying anything.  Well, there you go, he has to
be subject to rules
and I mean, if I feel
defamed, I have to be able to
attack him or I wouldn't like it if I were called a
pedophile or something, or if stories were made up
about me in something.
So I mean, there's
the internet, it's not a mess or anything.
So there is a need for
rules.  That's how it is, I mean, there
need to be rules for victims, just like there is
a problem with
that.  We can't say
total freedom either, and so on.  While I
am the biggest advocate of freedom
of expression, at some point I
am also aware of the
complexity of it all.  So I don't have a
solution since I was asked about it
today.  For me, it's
not an obsession to think about it, but
what I think is that someone with a
kind
of moral authority, like the High
Authority for Audiovisual Media, who
could, uh, how to say, be a kind of
clearing house or an
appeals body when there are
problems, that might
work.  I'm not sure if it's
the panassée, but there's
something to imagine around that.  Let me
explain.  Uh, I have, I have, there are tons
of people, I can give examples.
There are people who I remember a
guy who I think it was in the
Grenoble area who had done some who had who
was not at all a
journalist but who who was I
think an educator or nurse and who
spent his weekends or his time
worked for a site and who had
filmed demonstrations of police officers
beating women in a demonstration
and the police officers filed a complaint they
said that the thing was manipulated and the
guy was prosecuted, he was convicted
and so on.  He didn't have a
press card, the card commission did
n't defend him, and he ended up with nothing
and nothing.  This guy needs
defending because, well, he's probably
more of a journalist
than a Figaro editor who writes
whatever he wants, or some other
rag.  I say Le Figaro, it may be
a left-wing paper, I don't give a damn
, that's not it.  So there is, there is,
he is doing journalistic work, he is
doing work, but how do we measure that?
Because on the other hand you have a guy who will go
out once with his
iPhone, who will film a guy he doesn't like,
and then he will invent a story
around it, he will be prosecuted, it will be
normal that he will be convicted.  Well,
so there is, there is, and, and since nothing
exists, we can't always
protect ourselves from behind that.  There is another
problem, which is that I am considered in
any case as a journalist where I am
invited into schools, you
intervene with me on things like that.  I don't have a
press card.  Since 1980, it was
taken away from me in 1995, finally in 1997
because my royalties were
higher than the earnings I had in
press companies.  I even did a
press card, I created a precedent regarding press cards because I proved that even
if you were an author, they gave me back my
press card for years, then
after I wrote novels and
stuff I didn't have it anymore.  But so we can clearly see
that to say that a journalist is
only someone whose income,
because that is the
definition of a journalist today
in France, is that more than 50% of their
income must come from a
press company.  But that means that you
sometimes have communications directors who
have press cards.  That's why, at the time, I had this so-called
trial against the
press card.  And you have
another debate that really got my goat, it's the
whole thing with Bachelot and that
group of girls from Direct 8, what's
their name?  I don't know anymore.
Ferrari, the girl, plus the other one, well,
she and Bachelot started to open her
mouth to say, "Wait for us, it's
normal that we have a press card
because we do a
journalistic job," and so on. The press
card commission told them no, and then she
explained that she had something happen,
she said, "But look, these
guys are hacks, these guys
from the press card commission,
because they're not in the spotlight
like us, out of frustration they
prevent us from having the card," and so
she tried to develop the idea that
when we did entertainment, we
deserved the press card too.  I
think that's heresy, basically.  And
that it's normal that these people, these
girls, and it would be the same for guys
, don't have their press card
because they do entertainment,
because they talk nonsense on
TV, well, I don't know what.  And so
the anger she felt was
overblown.  And if she wanted a
press card, she only had to do like me,
she only had to take a measurement,
request an exemption and there would be a
judgment.  At some point
, a decision must be made as to whether people are
capable of having a press card or
not.  And I think that the
card commission does not have the
means to achieve its ambitions, but
fortunately there are journalists,
these unsung heroes of information, or
these galley slaves, these guys who,
outside of their working hours, are at the
card commission.  Luckily
they're there to keep the shop going a bit,
but I think they need some
help.  I think we need to
strengthen the arsenal.  So it's very
complicated because afterwards you
immediately create a council like in
doctors' offices and that's not what is being
asked for.  So we need to find
something, we need to find something, we need to build
on what already exists to create what
I called the
clearing house, maybe journalists.   That
is to say, there is a place where everything that
is contentious and problematic
can be judged by a kind of wise man
who would then, after the problem of
appointing them by the National Assembly,
journalists and all that, creates
castes, creates all that.  We need to
find a democratic way and
agree that everyone should create this
commission, which is not like the high
authority, which is still a kind of thing
where guys come to collect money
because they have done
services, you know.  And so I don't find it
terrible either.  But there are
things like that that need to be invented.  In any
case, democracy is something we are only at the
beginning of addressing these issues.  We will no
longer be able to avoid asking ourselves these questions
.  It will
really be necessary, but because there will be so much
injustice and there is already so much looming that
if the
legislator and if the professionals or
the don't try to propose
things and think about all this, we are
going towards mini catastrophes which
may lead to big ones
.  We would like your opinion on
the Snowdon affair.   This
young man, I found it incredible that
France did not give him
asylum, it was just a matter of justice, but here we are in
geopolitics, we are in
realpolitik and we are in, well, you can't
attack the United States with impunity.
I've read quite a bit about it.  So
I read quite a few things, even
in newspapers.  I think I read that
in Rolling Stone where they explained
that Stanon was a right-wing activist
who had
completely different views, we try to say whether he is
right-wing or left-wing.  Honestly, I don't care
.  This guy deserves
a medal, just like you deserve
a medal for
Bradley Manning, and obviously for Sange,
more so for Bradley Manning than for Sange.  They are, they are,
they deserve
Nobel Prizes for freedom.  These are the people we need, we need to,
we need to erect statues for them, we
need to, we need to, we
need to welcome them to France with
open arms.  Because it's still
incredible that this guy demonstrates how much
the Americans
finally listened to us in a way that we
knew, that we suspected.  But here we
read it, we see it, and you have these kinds of guys
who are practically touching the
walls there.  You can clearly see those guys
in power who don't want to get too hung up
on the issue.  And and I find that
, I find that, I voted for them
but I might still vote on the
left obviously but it's
unbearable, it's unbearable and and
these people are doing politics but they're
not doing politics.  So they have
no courage, they have none and they
are selling their souls, they
have lost, they are
losing all the battles.  It's funny
because they're losing them one by
one.  I was still watching
Manuel Val, there's a video circulating
on the internet.  3 or 4 days later, he was
approached by a woman in Trappe.
This video is incredible, you have to
watch it.  Val, that's completely
pathetic.  He's pathetic.  He doesn't have the
courage to look this woman in the face when she
says things, things that are obvious.
And there we see
how compromised socialism is in power, how
afraid it is of its numbers, you know.  Finally, that's what's happening
, there's a climate of
unease that's been established among these
people, you know.  And yet you're still approaching
them to finance your
documentary channel project?
But that's not it, no, I'm not talking to
them.  That's not it.  I made an
idea for a documentary channel, it's where
I switch from one to the other.
When I see the crap on
TV on these channels, when I see that
public money is used to pay for Guli, the
kids' channel, or that even my
mom, who is willing to watch
Japanese cartoons, can't stand that
when I see it going to France 4
for stupid presenters who don't
even know how to speak French, it's not the
problem of speaking French where it pays for
American series.  With a
quarter of the public money budget for this
thing, we could make a real
doc channel, what I called Doc Dog TV.
I mean, with much less
money, I think we can create something
great that can eventually, in the
medium or long term, compete with
things like YouTube or
projects like Google TV that are emerging,
and so on.  So, we need to create, I
need the I find it normal
in a democracy like this
with the left in power that a
Minister of
Culture can, since these are
conversations I have had with her,
can help, it would do her good to
have a good project because
for now she is she
defends a certain number of ideas
and so on, but I don't see her having
incredible projects and this project is
a good project and that public money
can be used for this, it seems fair
and good to me.  Especially since I'll end on this note
, if you knew the number of
incredible documentaries that are in
the cellars and bins of France
Télévision and Arte, you'd be blown away
.  Because these channels
operate with
public money, they need...
I know this because I'm a
documentary producer, so I see how it
works.  Films are shown once, then
forgotten even though they're there and there are
loads of people who could
see them in high schools, schools, and
universities.  There are some
amazing things to invent about that.  That's why
with my two or three friends, uh,
Alain de Greff, uh, Lyonna,
Bordeaux, and others, we
imagined
this associated platform and the life
of the TV channel, it's a showcase.
So there you have it, public money, yes,
public money, it's better that it be
used for this rather than paying for American
TV series.  That was the
idea, wasn't it?  a way to
remain a little bit affiliated, or even a
little subservient to the current policy,
to finally get financed only
through this channel, whereas you could
also get financed through the
public, which is your
own, and also even with, for
example, a
Kickstarter-style production that would allow you to finance
other documentaries.  What is
voyeur, sorry, actually you're posting a
project.  Ah yes, and depending on
public interest, everyone puts in 10 dollars and
so on.  But the project involves
new documentaries.  All right.  I
see what I meant.  But in
the Dogdc TV project there is the idea that it is
a very cheap paid film project
but when you want to watch
documentaries.  So there are shop windows
where there are free films and then there is
a kind of
huge database and when you want to watch them you
pay €1 or €2 you can subscribe.
Finally, there's a whole system like that.
So, it's not just
public money, but to initiate all
this, documentary being the art of
knowledge, being the art of understanding.   That's why
I think that
when we make
documentaries, we have so much trouble
making them and we put a part of our heart, our
soul, and so on into them that we want
to distribute them.  When I go to high
schools or
universities to show my documents,
the rooms are packed.  It creates
debates, I can't spend my life on that
.  That's why it's from this
platform; it could be great.
That said, there is such heaviness,
Philippe Étier, he is surrounded by graduates of the École Nationale d'Administration (ENA),
she is surrounded by others, and then she has
other things to think about.  So that's why
I wrote him this
open letter.  I don't think he liked it very much
.  That said, well, it was
like a message in a bottle. I do
n't know if she'll hear it.  I don't think so, actually
.  I think we're going to have to find another way
.  And so
, this is where the internet comes into
play. Advertising
an educational channel that promotes
values, the values ​​of the
common good, on the internet strengthens a population's
intellect and its
critical thinking skills.  When we are faced with a
journalistic dogma, I take the
journalistic dogma, the economic journalistic dogma
.  When people learn
via the Internet, through
serious documentaries compared to
lost or obscure economists who are
really addressing the
Internet community, don't you think that
French legislators have
no interest in producing an
educational channel that could strengthen
the critical thinking of a population?
No, I think that, how can I
put it, we must avoid making
overly general judgments like that
.  I think Vincent Payon is
a better minister than Luc Châtel, for
example.  I prefer to vote; I think
what this government is doing for
education is more interesting than what
the previous one was doing.  Besides, my
goal is not to create a channel of
knowledge, it is to broadcast and
offer a showcase to thousands of
documentaries that are forgotten.  And I
predict, we may not get
fantastic audience figures at the
beginning, but I think that
young people, teenagers or even
children are interested in the art
of documentary.  Al, what do you
think of a documentary about Coca-Cola
that will challenge legislators
regarding the regulation of X
chemical substance?  Are you
aware of the extent of the pressure that was
put on the publishers of this
documentary?  I've heard about
the story.  What can you
tell us about the pressure that
documentary filmmakers face on
sensitive topics that involve
legislators?  So, that's the
problem, the documentary issue
is complicated because in France we
are extremely privileged.  I have
Spanish friends who come to France to
finance their film, there's not a
penny left over there.  In France, we are
private because we have the CNC.  So, I
know that it is very criticized that there are
castes there, that there are people
who think they are something special.  I'm not one,
I think we have a formula that
works and that is pretty
good.  Simply, there are
tricky subjects and I have there are
films that I wanted to make a film
about Cavana, it is impossible to
finance a film about Cavana.  I'm
forced to resort to crowdfunding or
things like that.  But there are
issues and issues in France when we
deal with finance as I
dealt with it with Clearstream, when we deal with
the nuclear industry, when we
really get to the bottom of things, when we are on
arms sales, when we are
on agri-food, they do some good
things but they are often
somewhat historical things that take
time.  When you take on
multinationals like that, Robin did it
with Monsanto for example, it's the same
problem, so she
found a system now that's
really good, which is that and that's the
strength of the internet, it's
subscriptions, that is to say you have to
have a name, you have to have projects that hold up
and you manage to finance
things like that.  And the film about
Coca-Cola, it will be seen.  In addition, there are...
I think it's a...
how to say?  It's obvious to
me to say this, that a democracy is,
you know, it's about
biorhythms.  A democracy needs
information, needs documentaries,
and when you muzzle all of that,
when you try to close the floodgates, there are
always places where it comes out
.  So we're going to find
independent cinema networks, we're going to find some
and there's the internet, you know.  That's it,
they can't do anything against the internet.
Not yet.  They can't do anything on the
internet.  No, but they can't do anything.  They
can make whatever laws they
want.  I mean, screw them,
whatever.  They won't succeed.
The determining factor in the Kusac case is
Kausac.  There are no guys like Kusak
.  There aren't many.  This
incredible kind of call, with which,
looking everyone in the eye,
he said, "I'm not lying, you can
believe me, and so on."  There was something there and
I thought to myself, this guy, I mean, I believed him
and I
believed him.  So maybe I had a preconceived notion about
Pleinel.  I know how much
this guy wants everything and
so I got more into it at some point,
I said I have doubts about that
.  But then from the moment there was
the gang plus Harfit a
rather serious journalist so I was I was
how to say I was I was asking myself a
lot of questions about it and I didn't deny it I had
sources from everyone and so
and the Kusac affair at the beginning the thing is that
Kusac what what.  His
personality, that kind of person, I
saw it again at the assembly there, the guy is
incredible, he has a kind of self-assurance.  I
think there are causes that there aren't
many in the
generations of politics, you know.  And that's
also what poses a problem.
That said, you see, it's a
great one because Kusac, that's
very good news.  That is to say, if there had not been
Kausac, uh because
uh let's remember
François Hollande's speech at Bourger, when I
saw François Hollande at Bourger
attacking finance and so on.
I thought it was pretty good, but I sensed it was a
big bluff.  Moreover, that's where he
wins a lot of
elections because he had a
Sarkozy opponent on the banking issue.  He
was pathetic, that Sarkozy paid by
Goldman Saxe.  Sarkozy is going to act as a
little telegraph operator everywhere.  Finally, someone who on
one hand tries to defend France
and on the other hand sells himself to the
bankers.  Finally, Sarkozy was, after all,
the man of the banks.  Finally, it was
said that he saved the banking system,
but well, he also got rich.  So,
in fact, you have a
socialist candidate who comes out
with a tone we saw that was
almost Golian, and in fact, he didn't do anything
.  Tax havens, the other one
Sarkozy explained to us a few
years ago that that's it, there were no more
tax havens.  My eye, they've never
looked so good.  And so I
wrote it, I said it, I can
prove it.  I can really talk to you at
length about this because I know
the issue well.  And then you have
Hollande, me, from the start, Hollande doesn't give a damn
about the issue of
tax havens.  That's just talk.  It was a
way of being in power.  And here's
the problem he has, so they do
little things in Brussels, but under the
pretext that Merkel, uh, their, their, if
they really had a
strong political will to fight against
tax havens, they had, they have
all the attitude to do it.  They don't.
He didn't do it.  The
good news about the USAC case is that he didn't do it
because they are, I
think, uh, uh linked not in a
corrupt way, but around
them there is a whole
political environment where we see the
links between finance and
the chinks.  Yeah, basically, basically
, that's it.  But what's
interesting about Kausac is that the
Kausac psychodrama is that for 3
months, he gritted his teeth, the guy
lied to public opinion.  And then you have
Media Park, which was fighting behind
PLEL, the Attorney General, and
then Media Park went to fabricate this
psychodrama, almost positively, because in the
end he wins and the guy gives up, and
there you still have a Minister of the
Budget, the main
tax fraud hunter, who is still in
the leadership of the power, who
lied.  Then afterwards he said he lied to the
president.  Finally, the commission
of inquiry is currently
studying all of this.  You have this man
who explains that he has an account in
Switzerland, that he committed fraud and so on, who
apologizes and so on, but the damage is
done.  And so at that moment, the
reaction of the authorities was quite
good because how else would you expect them to
act?  So, they saw the
black sheep and they said, "I
promise you, hand on heart, we're
finally going to change, and so on."  And
this situation forces them, forces them to
do more than just talk.  So, in
fact, he's taking Cameron with him
because Cameron and England are
also having problems.  So there,
I saw that things were moving a little bit near
the City but very quickly, you see,
we're talking about it a little less.  So,
we say that there will be, since this
story of, how to
say, communication on
tax information from one country to
another, it was in '96 the text of
the Geneva appeal, if you take it back,
it was exactly that.  So in 96, we
are in 20, in 30 years, it hasn't been
31 years, nothing
fundamental has happened.  And here
, when we read the papers and so on, we get the impression that things are
moving, that things are changing.
No way.  You have two countries that
refuse, namely Austria and
Luxembourg.  And you have the City saying
that it accepts, so London actually does
n't want to accept either.  So
all these things mean that you
have media frenzies like
that, and then afterwards you have in-
depth work.  Uh in Brussels, you have uh
3,400 or 500 banking lobbies for a lobby
uh which is uh we'll say uh
anti-banking, which is finance watch there.
But there is a force of the main
power, it is still the power of the
banks.  These are people
who are constantly holding up businesses and trying to make
us believe that we are the ones
stealing the money.  Finally, these are
incredible things, and the powers that be are
taken in by them.  And the
journalists too.  But obviously, so are the
journalists.  Obviously,
obviously.  But that's why, for
me, well, I'm answering your questions
because, well, you called me,
I know you a little, so I thought,
"Okay, it's an hour of my time and so on
."  But at the same time, I
find it relatively pointless.
That is to say, I know, we know, I know
more or less what's going to happen.   In other words, this is what's
going to happen,
business as usual
.  And at the same time, I believe
in books, I believe in information, I
believe in documentaries.  So my role
is to explain things and then
simply I am
someone who is the bad
conscience of journalism a little bit
because, well, for 10 years I
fought, I finally won but well, there you go
.  Besides, I'm not asking for anything
.  I don't care about medals.  I don't care about any of that.
I simply
think
that, uh, that my relative marginality,
uh, it's not me who has changed.  I have
n't changed.  I am the same person I was
when I was at Libération.  I have an
ethic, I have a code of
conduct, I have, well, then I
changed, I have had several lives,
I have done a lot of things, but it is
around me that there have been
renunciations, shifts.  It's the the I I I
here in a moment in
Libération, there was advertising,
then there were finance pages,
we were told that it was the evolution,
then we removed the letters to the
editor and there you go, then
Libération was sold to a banker and I
continue to read it by the way because
I find two good articles but
we can still see that the level has
dropped considerably.
And actually, you were talking about level
earlier with economics, doesn't the
fact that journalists
mostly come from a
literary background prevent them from having
a real critical eye on economics, for
example, on which they will be trained
by mainstream economists, who in
turn divulge the... I think, I think that today
a journalist who hasn't
read Frédéric Lordon isn't a good
journalist, you know.  So I'm not sure
that the mainstream media are both the
coach and the journalists.  I think that
being literary is more of
a quality in comparison, but at the same
time I have participated in
selections for journalism schools
and I can see that the profiles are
so diverse.  But what is
most striking, and this is one of the
things I develop in the
documentary series I just made, is
the incredible number
of job applicants every year
.  You have, I talk about in my
film that at Agnon, there were 3000, 2900
I think.  The one that is a
journalism unit in Brittany.  There were 2900
applicants in 2010 for 30 positions, 30
first-year students, that is.  In
and despite the journalist, the
most criticized profession in the
United States right now.  You have a
newspaper; they were having a terrible crisis.
Journalists' salaries have
fallen and there was a study done
by a job site
which explains that they finally did
a test but on a large number of
people, I think there were 40 or
50,000 people who answered the test,
that is to say what are the
jobs you prefer, how and
why?  Journalists, I think they're
arriving.  So, there are the 30
favorite jobs and there are the 30
hated jobs.  And journalists are 29th.
So, it's almost the I think that
behind journalist, there is lumberjack
in the hated jobs, you know.  But these
guys would rather go work in the
oil industry, be a secretary, go get
shot in Afghanistan than
be a journalist because it's a
population that doesn't earn much,
it's precarious and it's a shitty situation.
In the United States.  And in France, we're not there yet
.  There's always Laura,
by Albert Londres, and there you go.  But to
journalists, you go to the United States,
you talk about Washington, about
how the president's men,
everyone has forgotten what.  Finally, is
lowering journalists' salaries just another
way
of making them
even more precarious and
malleable, that is, of tightening the
leash of power around their necks?
This is what Allain Cardo denounced
15 years ago in one of his books.
Allain Cardo is a formidable
sociologist.  Uh, he was the one who
first developed the idea
of ​​media workers, you know.  We are right in the middle
of the media workers phase.   Uh, that is to
say, uh, we're on the internet
with all of this, the articles
signed by people who are
Stacanovic of the news or Chiva of
the news who film, who do this, who have to
do three articles a day, who
are, what do you want?  You
make news but
you don't provide information.  So it's
less a problem of
wages than a problem of the
system itself.  And I know what I'm
talking about because I'm currently trying
to create an
internet portal, which will be
called "Info of the Day," where we're going to
try to hire journalists.  We'll
try because I started with
the idea that free internet, me
walking on advertising and so on,
and I've come back to that, I think that
today, moreover, the
regional daily press is
sinking and the
national press is in very bad
health.  So there is room
for a quality journalist and I
bet that people will
subscribe more and more to
news sites.  But you have to be good, you
have to bring added value, you have to
be serious, rigorous, you have to
work.  So, this comes at a price, and if
it doesn't work, well, it won't work.  But
anyway, sorry, we're going to
embark on this adventure right now.
Finally, I'm working on it.  One last question
to finish: if you had one piece of advice to
leave, a message in a bottle to
leave on the internet for the young people
watching us, what advice would you give to
sharpen their critical thinking skills?  I'll
add a little something
extra.  What would the journalist's oath be
in its 2013 version?  No,
but it's about staying
curious.  It's like finding
a truffle, you know?
That takes time.  Well, that's it, you should
never believe what you're told.  The "
we" being the media, politicians, and
so on.  But at the same time, we shouldn't
see conspiracies everywhere;
journalism remains an
essential profession, one cannot simply become a
journalist, but on the other hand, anyone can perhaps
become a journalist through hard
work, self-improvement, and
acculturation.   In other
words, to be a journalist,
you have to be cultured, you have to read, you have to be
interested in current events, you have to
read books.  Literature is very important
.  I mean, I
learn more about journalism by reading
Tom Wolf or even Richard Brotigan than by
reading essays.  or some or some swollen ones
finally so there is it is of a it is it is of
great complexity I I
and it was then I I
think it was probably easier a
few years ago to to
earn a living as a journalist
today today it is it is it is
probably more difficult and
again I think we are in a it is
difficult at the moment because we are
in a world is
collapsing.  If people haven't
seen it, it's because they are blind.  But
when you're a bit closer to the heart of the
systems, you can clearly see that there's a
permanent collapse.  Finally, and at the same
time, things are being
reborn and we will probably arrive
at a kind of rebalancing because, once again
, a democracy
cannot live without information.  So, can she
live without a
journalist?  I don't think so.  I don't
think so because journalists
are the guarantors of this
information.  Then, it's about
defining who they are.  It's
certainly not Claire Chazel, who
for me is not a
detestable person, she is
pleasant to deal with, but for me, it is not
through her that journalism
is not the future of journalism.  This is
the end of this kind of journalism.  So there are forms of
journalism emerging from all over the place
.  Uh, but we need to, uh, well, we
need to prioritize, we need to, the
web is a, is a, is a, is a world
still in development, you know.  But we must also
not forget that today
the 8pm news has 8 or 9 million viewers
.  Radio stations
are widely listened to.  The internet is not a
panacea, but we know very
well that in 20 or 30 years, well, there you go
, everything will come from there.  clinging to the good
of
nothing.
Ultraliberalism or
libertarianism, which basically means
there is an invisible hand of the market, which
above all means, but wait, don't have
as your only personal behavior to be
selfish.  In fact, the prism is just
a specific subprogram of a
more general plan.  In the past, it
was called, and it is also part of a
program that we know
called the Gon.
So, neither the Russians nor the Chinese
want the UN to turn into
a machine for giving good and
bad governance scores.
[Music]